la convención de estambul un tratado
internacional para la protección de los
derechos de la mujer y en contra de la
violencia en contra ellas tanto de
mujeres comunidades fue aprobado en 2011
dentro del consejo de europa una
organización en el que está en la
mayoría de países europeos también
turquía rusia y otros países esta
convención por aprobada por 34 países la
mayoría dentro de la una europea como
españa francia italia o alemania y por
turquía que este viernes pasado a por
absoluta 2 fecha de todo el mundo se
salió de este tratado el debate sobre el
tratado de la convención de estambul
empezó no ahora sino hace muchos meses a
por allá en verano en 2020 cuando el
presidente turco recep tayyp erdogán y
miembros de su gobierno empezaron a
hablar de su intención de salirse de ese
tratado según ellos aseguran a este
tratado para proteger a las mujeres va
en contra de la tradición familiar en
turquía y protege dicen ellos a los
homosexuales algo a lo que no pueden
llegar a soportar ni entender los
islamistas turcos sin embargo este
tratado ha creado muchas
muchos intentos para protegerlo dentro
sobre todo de los grupos feministas en
el país que en verano se manifestaron
masivamente para luchar para que el
acuerdo siguiese en vigor de hecho
también había mucho debate dentro del
propio gobierno siendo la mujer de
receta de perdonan emine erdogán y una
de sus hijas defensoras de este pacto
sin embargo el debate terminó en verano
y ahora mismo por sorpresa absolutamente
de todos en un decreto firmado a las dos
de la madrugada del viernes pasado
erdogán decidió que turquía se sale de
este pacto